the census of marine life has released
the most comprehensive inventory of life
in the ocean to date it's an
unprecedented database of marine species
living in 25 key ocean areas around the
world the findings published in the open
access scientific journal PLoS ONE
describes species found in oceanic
regions ranging from icy Antarctic
waters to the tropics to temperate
waters throughout the world
and the Arctic this is the first time
ever that all the information is
available in one single source for the
public worldwide so anyone around the
world who wants to know about Caribbean
marine biodiversity for example just
goes to one place clicks we'll have a
full article and then we'll also have
through the supporting material we'll
have list of species of the most
representative or most studied groups in
the area the study found that some of
the largest and best-known sea creatures
make up only a tiny portion of the
oceans biodiversity animals like whales
seals sea birds turtles and walruses
account for only 2% of the known marine
species in the 25 regions while
crustaceans including crabs lobsters and
shrimp account for nearly 20 percent
microscopic algae and single-celled
organisms are the most widespread
researchers observe these tiny organisms
throughout the studied areas the waters
of Australia and Japan share the title
of most biodiverse each with almost
33,000 known species nearly 3 times the
average researchers also found that some
of the top 5 most diverse areas are also
the most threatened these include the
waters of the Mediterranean China and
the Gulf of Mexico
having an open access database that is a
framework of the known marine
biodiversity is one of the most useful
tools you can have not just for
scientist but especially for policy
makers because they are the ones who
will make the decisions about what will
be done with the oceans what measures
will be taken to protect it but even
with this new inventory of the sea much
work remains to be done
census scientists estimate that for
every known oceanic species at least
four more have yet to be discovered
and while future research will continue
to expand our knowledge of the ocean
these latest findings represent a giant
leap forward in our understanding of the
wild and wonderful creatures that call
it home
you